it's 1989 and we're here in Panama where
the U.S has control of a very important
canal and luckily the Panamanian
dictator has been very friendly to
American interests but the U.S starts
losing confidence in this guy wondering
if he's really the best choice ensuring
the U.S maintain easy access to their
vital Canal oh and it didn't help that
this guy was indicted in Florida on drug
trafficking and money laundering charges
we gotta get him out but the straw that
broke the camel's back for this guy was
when Panamanian troops killed an unarmed
American soldier in Panama City the U.S
is done with this guy so they invade
Panama with 27 000 troops Panama's
military is crushed and the dictator is
eventually arrested and sentenced to 40
years in prison and the U.S ensures
access to its Canal after all foreign
[Music]